qu'on l'a dit le destin de cette réforme
des retraites va se décider aussi dans
la rue demain dans les rues donc on l'a
évoqué de 265 villes françaises grève
niveau de mobilisation et de services
publics plus ou moins garantis ce qui
nous attend demain avec Jérôme arabier
suivant il y a la bataille politique
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat et celle dans
la rue menée par les syndicats pour ce
mardi le mot d'ordre est clair mettre le
pays à la raie avec une mobilisation
historique attendue par les leaders
syndicaux je pense qu'on peut faire plus
fort que le 31 janvier dernier qui était
déjà la plus grosse mobilisation depuis
le début des années 90 donc vous savez
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion le
montrent il y a un profond rejet des 64
ans dans l'opinion il y a un profond
rejet de cette réforme des retraites
dans les transports les prévisions sont
noires avec seulement un train sur 5
pour les TGV TER et ouigo c'est encore
pire pour les lignes Intercité avec
aucune circulation programmée même int
dans les transports franciliens avec un
trafic très perturbé à la RATP pour les
RER A et B intrins sur 3 est annoncé
dans certains secteurs comme l'énergie
les actions sont déjà lancées avec une
réduction importante de production
d'électricité et dans les raffineries la
CGT appelle à une grève reconductible un
durcissement que le gouvernement dénonce
nous ne sommes pas favorables bien
évidemment au blocage nous l'avons dit
répéter et il y a un certain nombre
d'expressions mettre l'économie à genoux
par exemple qui ne sont pas entendables
et je suis convaincu nous sommes tous
convaincus au gouvernement dans la
majorité que l'expression d'un désaccord
c'est légitime mais ça ne doit pas
entraîner un blocage du pays qui serait
dangereux pour notre économie les
manifestations se dérouleront en même
temps que le débat au Sénat ou les
oppositions de gauche comptent s'appuyer
sur la mobilisation syndicale il y aura
une mobilisation qui va être très forte
et derrière cette mobilisation cette
journée de demain derrière on va
attaquer on va parler de l'article 7 du
fameux reportage jusqu'à 64 et forcément
il va falloir que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités les syndicats se
réuniront à l'issue de la journée de
mobilisation pour décider de la suite à
donner des actions ponctuelles sont déjà
prévues le 8 mars journée internationale
des droits des femmes mais comme dans
les raffineries certains secteurs
appellent désormais à lancer une grève
reconductible pour tenter de faire plier
le gouvernement effectivement c'est
l'une des informations de cette fin de
lundi après-midi 3 des 4 terminaux
métaniers qui permettent d'importer du
gaz naturel liquéfié en France ont été
mis à l'arrêt pour cette jour je vous
présente tout de suite les invités de ce
second débat autour des enjeux du 7 mars
leur Salvin bonsoir bienvenue directrice
générale de cantars publics Franck Morel
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous à
Avocats Associés chez Flichy Grangé
ancien conseiller social à Edouard
Philippe et expert emploi à l'Institut
Montaigne Jean-Marie Pernaut bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes politologue
chercheur à l'Institut de recherche
économique et social et vous publiez le
syndicalisme d'après
aux éditions du détour et Mathieu
croissanto éditorialise politique est
resté à mes côtés évidemment leur Salvin
je commence avec vous
qu'attendent les Français de la journée
de demain peut-être difficile de
répondre mais quelle est la part de ceux
qui vont participer qui veulent
participer et ceux qui restent malgré
tout un peu plus spectateurs qui observe
le bras de fer je crois que si on prend
un petit peu de recul par rapport à ces
dernières semaines même ces derniers
mois depuis l'annonce finalement de
cette réforme des retraites ce qui est
vraiment marquant c'est cette grande
stabilité de l'opinion c'est à dire que
depuis le départ l'opinion française
elle rejette de façon majoritaire cette
réforme des retraites telles qu'elle est
présentée elle soutient la mobilisation
contre la réforme et notamment la
mobilisation demain de demain donc elle
est plutôt même ad au niveau de soutien
de la mobilisation dans sa forme de
grève reconductible il y a une maturité
de Français qui est favorable ou pas
alors il y a une légère majorité de
Français qui est qui est favorable mais
tout le monde plutôt d'accord sur la
journée de mobilisation de demain
ensuite c'est beaucoup plus
distendu et beaucoup moins fort je
dirais comme soutien et puis il y a
aussi de la même façon une grande
stabilité sur le sentiment que la
réforme va quand même être appliquée et
qu'elle va être prise de toute façon par
le gouvernement et moi ce qui marque
c'est que ça n'a pas bougé depuis
plusieurs semaines et même plusieurs
plusieurs mois comme si les débats qu'il
y avait eu alors à l'Assemblée nationale
maintenant au Sénat et puis même sur les
évidemment sur les différents médias
dans les différents médias n'avaient pas
eu d'impact sur l'opinion des Français
ni d'un côté ni en termes de ralliement
au gouvernement le français aurait pu se
dire finalement je comprends les
arguments des du gouvernement et donc
j'adhère davantage à cette réforme ni
j'ai envie de dire à un autre projet
différent sachant que finalement il n'y
a pas eu vraiment d'autres projets qui a
été proposé sur cette réforme des
retraites vous étiez je l'ai dit
conseiller social d'Édouard Philippe à
Matignon lors de la réforme 2019-2020 et
vous 2020 et vous étiez aussi sera
adjoint le cabinet d'Eric verte là
c'était 2010 et dans les deux cas il y a
eu une pression de la rue qui avait été
évidemment très forte
témoignage de l'Intérieur à quel point
vous en tenez compte dans les
négociations vous voyez parce que c'est
c'est là c'est ce qu'on se demande les
chiffres de demain j'imagine qu'ils
doivent commencer à circuler on sait
qu'il va y avoir une mobilisation très
forte à quel point ça impacte un
ministère ou un cabinet de Premier
ministre ça l'impact dans la manière de
conduire la réforme ce qui est certain
en tout cas c'est que le sujet des
retraites
de mémoire assez lointaine est un sujet
qui ne peut pas être réformé sans grande
difficulté c'est un sujet qui est tout
sauf consensuel et si vous si on fait
l'historique de l'ensemble des réformes
des retraites qui ont été menées on ne
peut citer aucune réforme majeure des
retraites qui a été menée sans qu'il y
ait eu des secousses a fait importante
par exemple effectivement vous parliez
2010 en 2010 il y a eu 14 manifestations
dont quatre qui ont dépassé le million
je citerai pas à 1995 et en 2019 aussi
extrêmement compliqué alors 2019 le film
s'est arrêté parce que est passé par là
un certain nombre d'autres éléments
notamment le covid effectivement qui
fait que la grille d'analyse sur ce qui
s'est passé en 2019 est un peu brouillé
par rapport à celle qu'on peut
transposer sur d'autres réformes mais ce
qui est certain c'est que c'est toujours
extrêmement difficile il y a quatre
éléments majeurs d'expérience qui me
paraissent importante notamment en
matière sociale sur pour la conduite des
réformes et pour les chances de succès
de pouvoir les mener à bien il y a
d'abord la capacité à démontrer et à
faire partager le fait que la situation
de départ n'est pas satisfaisante et que
la réforme est nécessaire il y a ensuite
deuxièmement le fait d'avoir une vision
très claire de la direction où on veut
aller qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire à
travers la réforme est-ce qu'on est
capable de l'expliquer simplement il y a
ensuite le fait de pouvoir faire en
sorte que la réforme soit perçue comme
étant légitime soit légitime parce
qu'elle a été négociée soit légitime
parce qu'elle s'appuie sur un programme
électoral et puis enfin quatrième pilier
c'est le fait de pouvoir avoir une MA
volonté au Parlement sur lequel on peut
s'appuyer on se rend compte quand on
regarde ces quatre éléments que quand on
arrive à avoir au moins trois des quatre
on arrive à passer là en 2019 il y avait
un point qui manquait et qui était
crucial c'était la clarté c'était assez
compliqué d'expliquer voilà et puis et
là qu'est-ce qui manque activer la
nécessité le gouvernement a pas
suffisamment réussi à montrer qu'il
était nécessaire sans doute de réformer
premier point et puis la clarté qui au
début y était plutôt sur la question de
l'âge elle est assez peu perçue sur les
autres paramètres de la réforme et donc
c'est sans doute une partie de la
difficulté Jean-Marie Pernot l'une des
inconnus de la semaine c'est quoi c'est
la mobilisation dans le privé par
exemple vous diriez ça
l'inconnu c'est de savoir si un
mouvement essentiellement visible à
travers des manifestations peut devenir
un peu autre chose je crois que c'est
tout le pari de la journée de demain la
formulation qui a été employée par les
syndicats la mise à l'arrêt le pays à
l'arrêt qui n'est pas un appel à la
grève la grève générale etc c'est un
petit peu ça interroge un petit peu
chacun sur ce qui peut apporter
[Musique]
le côté un peu un peu figé de l'opinion
voulait intervenir non il y a aussi un
autre élément c'est la gestion du temps
et la gestion en bon français du
storytelling c'est-à-dire comment est-ce
qu'on est capable à partir d'un projet
de départ de montrer qu'on est qu'on
fait évoluer un certain nombre de choses
au fur et à mesure de cette gestion du
temps et là la difficulté dans le cas
d'espèces c'est que au regard du
contexte particulier au Parlement et de
la majorité relative et bien le
gouvernement a dû brûler pas mal de ses
cartouches au début du process
normalement dans ce type de processus on
a un projet on les garde les graines on
les garde pour le lendemain des grosses
manifestations des graines un certain
nombre de choses où on les égraîne pas
d'ailleurs en fonction de la situation
mais on a une capacité à faire évoluer
dans le temps en fonction des
soubresauts en fonction des à-coups là
la grande difficulté c'est que les
cartouches ont été brûlées et même plus
encore plus qu'un certain nombre de voix
dans le cadre du débat au Sénat
notamment mettent en avant le fait que
on est dans le dur sur le fait
d'utiliser les par la réforme et qu'on
est un petit peu au-delà de ce qui
serait tenable pour que la réforme
remplisse son objet c'est à dire de
ramener le système à l'équilibre entre
leviers généralement qu'un gouvernement
actionne c'est soit il essaie de
retourner l'opinion publique là il n'y
parvient pas parce qu'il a perdu la
bataille d'opinion il a tous ces
éléments de langage tout le fameux
storytelling plus personne ne l'entend
tout le monde trouve cette réforme
brouillonne malfaite et injuste et en
tout cas les deux tiers des Français et
l'autre V c'est d'essayer de diviser ou
de fissurer le front syndical en
essayant d'apprêter les uns ou les
autres avec justement un aménagement
voilà et là le gouvernement on est privé
également parce qu'effectivement alors
ce qui est paradoxal c'est que il y a
des discussions de la part du
gouvernement éventuellement
effectivement du lest qui a été lâché
mais à la majorité elle est au Sénat ou
ou elle est en général pas à l'Inter
syndical c'est c'est ça qui est
paradoxal dans ce dans ce débat depuis
des semaines tout à fait et puis même je
pense qu'il y a eu des concessions qui
ont été faites avant même de présenter
le texte qu'on a entendu en tout cas et
ça en effet en termes de c'est assez
stratégie oui de stratégie c'est
terrible parce qu'en fait on a le
sentiment que finalement il y a eu des
négociations en chambre on sait pas
exactement quoi elles n'ont pas vraiment
été dites et souligné et donc le
gouvernement apparaît plutôt comme très
rigide très finalement campé sur sa
réforme et qui ne veut juste
effectivement que bouger les lignes sur
les propositions DLR essentiellement
parce qu'en fait sur les autres on les
entend pas du tout alors demain
l'intersyndical espère plus de monde
dans les rues que le 31 janvier dernier
qui était la journée la plus forte
jusqu'ici c'est ce que disait Laurent
Berger ce matin chez nos confrères de
France Inter je pense que demain nous
devons avoir une turne mobilisation
extrêmement puissante ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire d'abord beaucoup beaucoup
de gens dans les rues beaucoup de gens
dans les manifestations il y a encore
plus de lieux de rassemblement que les
autres fois il y en a plus de 250 260 et
il faut donc j'appelle les salariés de
ce pays les citoyens de ce pays les
retraités de ce pays qui sont contre la
réforme des retraites à 64 ans à venir
manifester massivement Jean-Marie Pernot
est-ce que la journée demain si on fait
un peu d'histoire sociale est-ce qu'elle
peut rentrer dans dans nos livres
d'histoire sociale
à la journée demain elle sera marquante
elle sera marquante d'autant que bon
d'abord par son ampleur vous l'avez
évoqué même tous de laisser grande
séquences protestataires qu'on a connu
ces dernières années on a
incontestablement à faire à quelque
chose de plus important donc elle va
rester elle restera aussi on verra après
par ses conséquences parce que des
mouvements comme ça ça laisse des traces
plus que des traces à des effets
politiques forts au-delà de des
questions sociales qui sont évoquées
c'est des moments quand même moi que
j'appelle un peu démocratique parce que
les gens finalement s'intéressent aux
affaires qui les concernent d'habitude
il délègues ils élisent des gens qui ont
fait pour ça mais là on est dans des
moments où les gens sentent tout le
monde parle de ça aujourd'hui dans les
familles dans les cafés dans tout le
monde ne parle que de ça c'est vrai de
conversation des Français
en deuxième les Français alors
qu'effectivement jusqu'à présent c'était
plutôt dans les dixièmes sujets de
conversation et donc c'est des Mosses
donc c'est quelque chose ça aura des
incidences et je pense que cette
résignation vous évoquez à travers les
sondages ou les gens sont à peu près
conv vécu même s'ils sont en désaccord
avec la réforme qu'elle passera un peu
de fatalisme quoi un peu de fatalisme
mais c'est un fatalisme conditionné
c'est à dire que on se retrouvera dans
les urnes c'est ça que ça veut dire
parce que tous ces mouvements là ont des
effets dans les urnes 95 que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure deux ans après
Jacques Chirac dissout s'attendant à
retrouver une majorité assez large et il
se prend en face
la gauche plus comment elle s'appelle la
gauche la gauche plus rien voilà c'était
la part laupes c'était la gauche pluriel
qui a surprise générale et c'était
l'effet direct de 95 donc on aura des
tire ces mouvements posent toujours la
question du gouvernement d'après et donc
ont des effets politiques on parle de
Laurent Berger il y a plusieurs
dimensions en fait il y a l'aspect
purement quantitatif et là sur cet
aspect là on peut s'attendre sans doute
vraisemblablement un chiffre record
puisque le chiffre record pour l'instant
pour mémoire il est celui dans le champ
social du 31 janvier précédemment il
était celui de octobre 2010 une
manifestation en octobre 2010 il a été
légèrement dép passé le chiffre record
tout domaine confondu c'est les
manifestations deuxième tour Chirac Le
Pen 2002 un million 300 il est pas
impossible que ce chiffre record soit
dépassé demain sont les chiffres
ministères de l'intérêt je prends
toujours les chiffres ministères
d'intérieur mais donc il est pas
impossible que ce chiffre là soit
dépassé demain bon après il faut
relativiser par de l'alaspect symbolique
qui est fort quand même effectivement le
caractère signifiant parce que si on
prend les manifestations gilet jaune qui
ont duré quand même pas mal de temps le
nombre des manifestants était toujours
relativement faible mais c'est
l'intensité la forte tension dans la
société française qui a fait qui a donné
toute la portée au mouvement des gilets
jaunes donc c'est pas uniquement une
question de nombre de manifestants c'est
aussi une question d'ancrage avec un
certain nombre de mouvements plus
profond et c'est là toute la difficulté
et c'est là ce qui rend extrêmement
humble sur l'exercice de pronostic et de
prévisions parce que personne
aujourd'hui n'est capable de dire de
manière rigoureusement précise ce que va
donner dans le ce mouvement est-ce qu'il
va donner après parce que c'est l'après
il faut aussi dès maintenant et pour le
gouvernement c'est un exercice qui est
hautement complexe il faut dès
maintenant se projeter dans la pré et
savoir comment après on renouer les fils
et qu'on recommencer à avoir un certain
nombre de projets dialoguer avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et bâtir ensemble
qu'il y a un personnage qui évidemment
joue un rôle central Mathieu c'est
Laurent Berger vous penchez sur sur la
personnalité du patron
si c'était lui l'homme fort de
l'opposition à la réforme alors
entendons-nous je veux pas dire que les
autres leaders syndicaux ne comptent pas
ce serait la foi faux il respectueux
notamment pour Philippe Martinez le
leader de la CGT oui mais voilà Philippe
Martinez il est à la fois dans son rôle
et sur le départ puisqu'il va quitter la
tête de la Confédération à la fin du
mois alors que Laurent Berger il est à
la tête d'un syndicat dit réformiste et
il a surpris plutôt son monde en
s'opposant si fermement à la réforme et
puis il vient d'être conduit à la tête
de la CFDT en juin dernier même si ça
marche de manœuvre est un peu encadré en
matière de retraite puisqu'on le
rappelle à une motion ont voté contre la
vie de la direction par les militants
lors du dernier congrès lui interdit en
effet d'accepter tout allongement des
carrières et ça explique sans doute en
tout cas en partie son opposition à la
réforme oui même si la motion concernait
surtout le sujet de l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation autrefois soutenue
par la CFDT en fait Laurent Berger il
est opposé au recul de l'âge légal qu'il
juge brutal et inéquitable il juge que
la réforme a été mal conçue sur le fond
comme sur la forme il a prévenu
l'exécutif tout au long de l'automne
n'a pas été pris d'une certaine façon
très au sérieux ces avertissements ont
compté pour du beurre parce qu'au sommet
de l'État on faisait le pari que le
leader de la CFDT sans soutenir la
réforme mais s'abstiendrait toutefois de
la combattre en restant fidèle à son
fameux ADN réformiste j'allais dire
social-démocrate mais mauvais pioche non
seulement leader de la CFDT a rejoint
l'intercy mais il n'a pas économisé ça
Salif pour dire tout le mal qu'il
pensait de la réforme dans les médias ni
son énergie sur le terrain pour
mobiliser ses troupes donnant un poids
considérable en mouvement parce qu'il
faut qu'on appelle ici la CFDT c'est la
première organisation syndicale de
France que dire de ces relations avec le
prénom République avec Emmanuel Macron
elles sont très très mauvaises alors que
Laurent Berger avait un lien direct avec
François Hollande avec Emmanuel Macron
le courant n'est jamais passé sur le
papier c'est bon on aurait pu imaginer
pourtant puisque Emmanuel Macron se
réclame et à l'époque en tout cas du
rocardisme il était pour le contrat
social ça c'est quelque chose qui peut
parler à la CFDT sauf que le même Lionel
Macron n'a jamais fait grand cas des
syndicats sauf quand il est dans la
panade il les considère davantage comme
des facteurs de blocage que comme des
partenaires il s'est assis dessus en
réformant par ordonnance les le code du
travail il s'est situe en revoyant la
baisse les critères de pénibilité dès
son arrivée à l'alizé alors lors de la
réforme avortée d'Édouard Philippe on en
parlait sur la retraite par point pour
le coup Laurent Berger avait de nouveau
joué le jeu mais il n'en n'a jamais été
vraiment remercier ni d'avantage écouté
c'est pourtant lui qui d'une certaine
façon détient les clés de ce conflit
mais l'exécutif se refuse toujours à le
traité parions sur le fait maintenant
que lorsque la loi sera votée la CFDT
syndicat légitimiste et non Ré
partenaires rentrera dans le rang sans
faire d'histoire ce qui reste à voir car
Laurent Berger n'a peut-être pas fini de
nous étonner merci Mathieu alors ça va
poser une question un peu qui pourrait
paraître un peu désagréable pour les
pour les leaders syndicaux mais est-ce
que est-ce que les Français font la
différence entre un Laurent Berger un
Philippe Martinez il y en a deux qui
sont identifiés et pas les autres
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire non
malheureusement et je pense que les
choses vont peut-être bouger avec les
prochaines semaines justement mais
jusqu'à présent les syndicats dans le
cœur de de l'opinion était plutôt
justement en Berre en fait c'est à dire
que les Français considérés que les
Incas n'aillent plus autant de pouvoir
qu'avant et les leaders syndicats non
plus d'ailleurs effectivement il y a
très peu de différenciation si on
demande aux Français de nous citer des
leaders syndicaux c'est très très
difficile
y compris d'abord un seul nom en fait
c'est c'est complexe pour relativiser
j'ai envie de dire c'est un peu la même
chose quand on demande aux Français de
nous citer des noms de ministres c'est
voilà c'est pas si évident que ça et là
on a quand même un vrai ce sera un goût
ça fera un gouvernement très très très
resserré c'est ça exactement peut-être
que c'est ce qu'attendent les Français
aussi d'ailleurs un gouvernement très
très resserré donc sur les leaders
syndicaux non malheureusement
aujourd'hui jusqu'à aujourd'hui en tout
cas c'était pas le cas et c'est vrai que
depuis plusieurs semaines pour le coup
on voit effectivement sur le devant de
la scène plusieurs personnalités et
plusieurs personnalités aussi qui
étonnent par leur choix cette union des
syndicats là notamment c'est assez
nouveau d'ailleurs et c'est plutôt ce à
quoi aspire les Français c'est-à-dire
faire de la politique différemment
s'allier quand c'est
utile sur certaines choses
exprimer des différences dans d'autres
situations mais là c'est fort probable
que les syndicats en tout cas que
l'image des syndicats finalement on
bénéficie à terme Jean-Marie Pernaut
c'est pas le Mathieu c'est pas une
surprise de retrouver Laurent Berger en
tête de cortège et à ce point opposé à
cette réforme on n'avait pas l'habitude
de le voir dans ce rôle mais si on
analyse l'évolution de la CFDT depuis
quelques mois vraiment pas seulement sur
la toute dernière période je crois qu'il
y a eu un décrochage avec les
ordonnances Macron de 2017 qui ont été
une arme de destruction massive des
syndicats dans les entreprises
c'est-à-dire qu'Emmanuel Macron avant
son élection dit moi les syndicats je
les respecte à condition qu'il reste à
leur place c'est-à-dire dans les
entreprises et les premiers actes qui
sont posés c'est une destruction des CHS
pour ça aujourd'hui quand on entend
parler de la valeur travail certains
souris parce que avoir brisé les CHSCT
c'est quand même dire
des conditions de travail du
vieillissement au travail et tout
c'était une belle manière d'entamer
d'entamer ce débat là et là là la CFDT
il y a eu un débat à l'intérieur parce
que les premiers mois la CFDT bon a
protesté contre les ordonnances Macron
mais assez modérément en revanche les
équipes syndicales ont vu en quoi ça se
traduisait sur le terrain et le
déplacement de la CFDT c'est les années
c'est ces dernières années et ce qui se
passe là ne doit pas bon alors c'est
surprenant pour ceux qui ne suivent les
choses que de manière superficielle mais
ça tient moins à la personne de leur
berger quel que soit la façon dont il a
piloté ce déplacement mais je crois que
il a été donné en profondeur de la CFDT
le Congrès est un moment pour le voir ça
il y a un débat pas bon moi je l'avais
vu parce que c'est bon c'est mon sujet
de travail j'ai aussi des débats très
souvent avec des équipes CFDT on voit on
voit quand même cette évolution depuis
plusieurs années bon vous avez ouvert
une parenthèse donc je vais quand même
donner la parole à Franck Morel sur
cette parenté sur les ordonnances Macron
arbres de destruction massive pour les
accords
pas trop long parce qu'il y a encore
beaucoup de thèmes mais je suis pas du
tout d'accord parce que les ordonnances
au contraire ont matérialisé un process
qui était à l'oeuvre depuis pas mal
d'années et dans lequel la CFDT avait
joué un rôle important qui est le fait
de donner beaucoup plus d'espace au
dialogues sociales et à la négociation
collective dans l'entreprise ça c'est la
réforme de 2008 et c'est la réforme de
2017 qu'il a permis aussi de manière
extrêmement importante donc je trouve un
peu réducteur de mettre en avant la
question des CHSCT de cette manière là
d'autant plus que quand on regarde
autour de nous en Europe on est entouré
de pays qui ont une seule et unique
instance de représentation du personnel
donc on était un peu une exception dans
le paysage et en plus je
trouveraisducteur de réduire le contenu
au contenant puisque les sujets
demeurent abordés et demeurent abordés
de manière encore plus efficace
justement avec une instance unique dont
on voulait justement qu'elle puisse
aborder de manière polyvalente et
générale toutes les thématiques donc je
suis un peu passionné sur la question je
vous prie de m'en excuser non mais bon
par rapport avec les deux opinions
s'expriment genre je reprends la main ça
pourrait faire un débat en soi pour
quand même pour je reviens vers vous
Jean-Marie Pernaut sur l'axe cfdtcgt qui
est quand même très solide depuis le
depuis le début de ce de ce mouvement ça
a pas toujours été le cas évidemment on
peut peut-être appeler l'épisode de 2003
donc là on est aussi dans une réforme
des retraites la CGT qui vit comme une
trahison la signature par Jacques Chirac
qui était le prédécesseur de Laurent
Berger
j'ai déjà accepté c'était le père
François merci Mathieu François cherrec
donc il décide de signer la réforme
Raffarin c'est très mal vécu par la CGT
c'est quoi c'est on surnomme le traître
à partir de ce moment-là donc oui bon il
y a eu des années de de rapports
difficiles mais ça va ça vient après il
y a eu les années Sarkozy pour faire
vite ou quand il était quand même un
facteur d'unité d'action aussi
signification et puis il y a la séquence
Hollande ou là la CFDT on le voit
inspire des projets de retraite la loi
Touraine la loi dit el khomri de 2016 la
CFDT joue le partenariat social et quand
elle a un interlocuteur c'était le cas
en tout cas sous les premiers
gouvernements de François Hollande ça
l'était un petit peu moins après mais
elle joue ce jeu là le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que le partenariat
pour avoir un partenariat il faut des
partenaires et qu'elle en a plus le
patronat de massigné a signalé que on
pourrait avoir des grands accords mais
qui était plus désaccords de gestion que
des grands accords de progrès social et
du côté du gouvernement
pendant la réforme 2020 il y a des
militants CGT je me souviens qui étaient
rentré au siège de la CFD
il y avait eu des oppositions voilà sur
les retraites parce que sur la réforme
systémique de 2019-2020 les syndicats
étaient dans des positions polaires
c'est-à-dire que la CGT le était
radicalement compte alors que la CFDT
même si elle a eu des états d'âme sur la
notion d'âge pivot et cetera malgré tout
elle est pour une réforme structurelle
de plus grande ampleur que cela mais
elle a toujours dit dès cette époque là
qu'elle ne voulait pas de réforme
paramétrique donc les signaux ont été
quand même très très très visible depuis
plusieurs années donc je n'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi les gens sont
surpris aujourd'hui que la CFDT soit
dans le conflit et même en bonne
position à moins de confondre
syndicalisme réformiste et syndicalisme
paillasson je crois qu'on peut pas trop
s'étonner que à un moment donné ils
disent trop c'est trop et que leur
crédibilité à eux-mêmes soit engagé si
je peux ajouter une dernière petite
chose oui non c'est sûr là ce qui peut
se passer après je voulais le dire tout
à l'heure on est passé à autre chose
assez vite mais pour l'instant c'est un
mouvement qui est très organisé tenu par
les syndicats il y a pas de déb là ils
ont donné trois semaines au Gouvernement
au Parlement pour bouger pour avancer
ces et là ils reprennent par un
mouvement galère encore une fois très
encadré mais si ce sentiment qu'on
beaucoup de gens que de toute façon la
réforme passera ça veut dire aussi que
ces mouvements ces manifestations
récurrentes au fond n'arrive pas
n'arrivent pas à déborder et imposer des
objectifs ce que je crains quand même et
un gouvernement soucieux de sécurité
publique devrait avoir ça à l'esprit
c'est qu'un certain nombre de gens et
peut-être enfin si on juge un peu les
réseaux sociaux il pourrait être assez
nombreux disent que bah il faut d'autres
moyens pour faire bouger le gouvernement
et d'ailleurs les gilets jaunes y
étaient à peu près parvenus et donc je
trouve que le souci d'ordre public m'a
l'air davantage pris du côté des
syndicats on avait compris
que par la puissance publique il y a les
réseaux sociaux et à ce que vous vous
percevez dans vos dans vos enquêtes
d'opinion tout à fait pour ce thème là
déjà effectivement sur ce thème là c'est
assez remarquable parce que depuis le
départ comme vous dites c'est
manifestations et cette mobilisation
contre la réforme elle est très bien
encadrée il n'y a pas eu de gros
débordements alors que effectivement on
s'y attendait les français eux ils
s'attendent justement à une explosion
sociale voilà ils disent quasiment à
80%, il va y avoir une explosion sociale
en France parce que les premiers mots
qui viennent à l'esprit quand on parle
de l'état d'esprit des Français c'est
lassitude colère peur et tous ces tous
ces sentiments en plus augmentent en ce
moment donc vraiment une crise passion
en même temps ils sont quand même à peu
près 52% à ne pas souhaiter cette
explosion sociale donc c'est là où
effectivement
ils anticipe quelque chose assez
agressif et en même temps ils ne le
souhaite pas et quand on regarde sur les
réseaux sociaux si justement ce que
disent les idées les gilets jaunes parce
qu'en fait les gilets jaunes on les voit
surtout sur les réseaux sociaux on les
voit dans les sondages mais aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux il y a pas pour le
moment en tout cas de mobilisation ou de
remobilisation très forte ou de
d'organisation de mouvements parallèles
je vais vous red la parole mais il y a
d'abord une phrase qui on va dire
focalise un peu ces divergences c'est la
volonté de mettre à genoux l'économie
française je vous propose de d'entendre
donner entendre le secrétaire général de
la CGT chimie Emmanuel les pas c'était
jeudi dernier de Marseille le but
partout c'est de désorganiser au maximum
la production et si la question c'est de
savoir si on veut mettre à genoux
l'économie française la réponse elle est
oui Franck Morel qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire ce pas sûr que l'expression soit
très heureuse parce que c'est confondre
effectivement un moyen et une fin le
moyen de la part des syndicats c'est
effectivement de d'utiliser tous les
moyens de pression possible pour faire
plier le gouvernement la fin n'est
certainement pas de mettre à genoux
l'économie française ça serait ça serait
dramatique effectivement non je voudrais
revenir après sur sur la question de la
violence que vous évoquez et qui risque
de violence alors d'abord pour
relativiser la question des réseaux
sociaux parce que les réseaux sociaux
sont toujours un démultiplicateur et
sont toujours renvoient un reflet un
miroir qui est toujours extrêmement
caricatural potentiellement de d'un
certain nombre de relations sociales en
revanche c'est vrai ça peut être une
vigie aussi ça peut être une vigieuse
ça peut être sur un certain nombre de de
questions qui peuvent remonter en
revanche effectivement il y a une ligne
de crête qui est qui est périlleuse et
qui est extrêmement compliqué qui
consiste à pouvoir et c'est ce que nous
évoquions tout à l'heure à travers le
storytelling et à travers le fait de
renvoyer régulièrement des signaux
pouvoir envoyer un certain nombre de
signaux de considération pour éviter
effectivement cette cette forme de
radicalisation quelque chose
d'extrêmement compliqué alors il y a
quelque chose qui est passé très
inaperçu dans le je dirais dans le cadre
de la séquence retraite c'est la corde
nationale interprofessionnelle qui a été
signée il y a peu de temps entre les
partenaires sociaux sur le partage de la
valeur je suis surpris que ça n'est pas
été plus valorisé que ça parce que
précisément le gouvernement
c'est très bien voilà le gouvernement
annonçant son attention de transposer
cet accord nationale interpro sur le
partage de la valeur je crois qu'Olivier
du soft a indiqué que ça serait
indépendant de la loi sur le travail qui
suivra c'est une manière en termes de
stratégie qu'aurait le gouvernement de
valoriser le dialogue social d'envoyer
des signaux sur la le souhait de
respecter scrupuleusement l'équilibre
qui a été trouvé par les partenaires
sociaux c'est tout ça qui va être
difficile de tisser je voudrais revenir
enfin également sur un point historique
par intéressant on parlait de des
relations avec les leaders syndicaux et
de la difficulté est-ce que est-ce que
oui ou non Laurent Laurent Berger a été
maltraitée en l'occurrence c'est que si
vous prenez les trois derniers
présidents que la France a connu chaque
début de quinquennat a été marqué par
une relation privilégiée avec un leader
différent au début du quinquennat de
Nicolas Sarkozy Raymond souby
social donc jouer pas mal la carte de la
CGT de Bernard Thibault à travers la
mise en avant de la position commune de
la réforme des règles de
représentativité souffrant le soit
Hollande vous l'avez rappelé c'est
Laurent l’interlocuteur privilégié et
dont on dit même qu'il était très
régulièrement contacté directement par
le président et au début du quinquennat
Macron la carte Jean-Claude Bailly a été
pas mal mise en avant justement par
rapport à la concertation qui était
organisée autour de ordonnances pour
obtenir une prise de parole de la part
de maïs qui était plus nuancée
par un leader un peu différent au regard
des contraintes du moment des stratégies
du moment toute la difficulté de
l'exercice c'est qu'effectivement vous
avez Emmanuel Macron et Laurent Berger
qui ont deux personnalités extrêmement
différentes vous avez un historique qui
est compliqué à gérer à travers le fait
vous l'avez rappelé que Laurent Berger
durant le quinquennat Hollande avait des
relations très régulières très étroites
avec le président de la République et
donc toute le challenge à relever pour
les pouvoirs publics dans la période qui
va s'ouvrir c'est comment être capable
d'avoir un projet suffisamment fort pour
créer quelque chose avec un ou plusieurs
leaders syndicaux je suis pas sûr que ça
soit avec le compte épargneau universel
ou avec le partage de la valeur je suis
pas sûr que ça suffise effectivement
pour cocher cette case donc ça va être
le défi qui va se présenter au pouvoir
public dans les mois à venir Jean-Marie
Pernaut l'Inter syndical dans sa
stratégie elle a pas d'autres choix que
de alors là il y a on peut dire mettre
la France à l'arrêt ou mettre l'économie
française à genoux je voilà je les
laisse libérer responsable de leur de
leurs expressions il y a pas d'autre
choix aujourd'hui sauf à plier dire on
rentre chez nous c'est terminé ce qui me
paraît difficile à envisager non ils ont
pas d'autre choix puisque manifester
remanifester et heureux manifester ne
semble avoir aucun effet sur la décision
gouvernementale il faut franchir un cran
enfin ça ils ont prévenu ils ont dit bon
voilà si ça ça suffit pas on laisse 15
jours trois semaines pour il y avait les
vacances ça tombait bien mais l'argument
était pas seulement celui-là s'il faut
donner de la respiration au mouvement
pour reconstituer des forces parce qu'on
peut pas faire grève toutes les la
semaine ou même trois fois par mois on
le sait bien donc on donne ce que ça a
donné l'argent
et puis bon bah là maintenant ils
essaient de franchir un cran et
effectivement quel que soit les mots
employés pour ça l'enjeu c'est quand
même d'avoir un effet sur l'économie
parce que c'est pour ça que le droit de
grève a été inventé si vous faites des
mouvements qui ne gênent absolument
personne ça sert à rien tout le monde
s'en fiche donc c'est pour ça aussi que
les syndicats de la SNCF ils se sont mis
à bloquer les trains à la veille des
départs en vacances parce que quand il
faisait grève à un autre moment tout le
monde s'en fichait oui mais enfin mettre
l'économie française à genoux c'est pas
forcément les plus riches de la société
qui ont souffriront mettons de côté une
expression quand on n'est pas obligé de
d'y applaudir mais les expressions dans
ce mouvement là on en a entendu de part
et de tous les côtés effectivement je
pense aussi que depuis les gilets jaunes
il y a cette idée qui est ancrée que
sans incident majeur il ne se passera
plus rien évidemment de le gouvernement
continuera à rester dans ses rails c'est
un peu comme le quoiqu'il en coûte quoi
il y a eu quand même on a cranté un
certain nombre de choses dans l'opinion
ces dernières années qui sont assez
malheureuses pour quelque part la
démocratie l'espace politique etc et
vous disiez que va-t-il se passer
ensuite par la suite parce que demain
est une chose pense que le vrai sujet
c'est pas ce qui va se passer demain
tout est à peu près annoncé grosse
mobilisation etc mais c'est plutôt les
jours dans les jours qui suivent et puis
les semaines qui suivent comment
continuer à faire de la politique dans
un climat pareil en fait un climat ou
finalement dans le sentiment que s'il
n'y a pas de violence ou de d'explosion
sociale il ne peut pas y avoir de
compromis et de négociations avec le
gouvernement c'est-à-dire
de nous rejoindre de nouveaux sur ce
plateau rebons soit Steve ce que dans ce
dans ce contexte social des sénateurs
veulent interdire les grèves pendant les
vacances et ils ont de la suite dans les
idées c'est pas une proposition nouvelle
il y a quelques années le Sénat avait
adopté une proposition de loi pour
instaurer un service minimum dans les
transports le texte et bien donner la
possibilité de réquisitionner des
grévistes pour assurer un service
minimum dans les transports publics au
moment bien des de pointe les jours de
grève le matin tôt l'après-midi tard le
texte avait été adopté sans opposition
de principe de la part du gouvernement
et Bruno Retailleau se réjouissait de
voir sa proposition adoptée écoutez-le
le dos de droite grève n'est pas un
droit de blocage d'un pays encore une
fois pensons aux françaises et aux
Français qui sont les plus dépendants
qui sont sans doute ceux d'en bas pas
ceux d'en haut ceux qui sont dépendants
justement pour aller venir pour
travailler le matin pour entrer le soir
c'est les Français du bas de même que le
droit de grève ça n'a jamais été un
droit de vie et de mort sur les
entreprises et sur les emplois il faut y
penser je pense qu'on doit pouvoir
équilibrer encadrer avec des limites le
droit de grève bien entendu mais aussi
faire en sorte qu'il y ait un minimum
garanti je pense que c'est dans la
nature des choses proposition de loi
adopter en 2020 par le Sénat et qui n'a
jamais été inscrite à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale et n'est donc
jamais entrer en vigueur Thomas et c'est
la raison pour laquelle le Sénat revient
la charge ces jours-ci il s'agit cette
fois de sanctuariser le début des
vacances et les jours fériés une
proposition de loi a été déposée par le
sénateur LR Stéphane rue dullier le
texte porte sur les entreprises de
transport public et privés il sera
désormais impossible pour les personnels
d'exercer leurs droits de grève la
veille le lendemain et le jour même d'un
jour férié ainsi que les deux premiers
et les deux derniers jours de chaque
période de vacances scolaire en gros
interdiction de faire grève pour les
salariés de la RATP pour ceux les
transports ferroviaires et ceux du
domaine aérien pendant ces périodes
c'est une idée qui s'inspire du modèle
italien mais est-ce bien constitutionnel
monsieur le rodulier
c'est effectivement c'est un droit
fondamental c'est pas un droit absolu le
droit de grève est inscrit dans la
Constitution italienne et pour autant
ils ont encadré ce droit de grève
notamment pour les jours fériés et les
vacances et les vacances scolaires alors
reste à voir si cette proposition de loi
sera effectivement examinée au Sénat si
elle sort ensuite reprise par le
gouvernement par l'Assemblée nationale
et le cas échéant si elle sera jugée
constitutionnelle par le Conseil
constitutionnel ça fait beaucoup de
signes c'est effectivement beaucoup de
immersive Jourdain Franck Morel le ce
qui se passe en Italie on peut s'en
inspirer moi et puis au-delà de cette
question
ressortir ce thème là en plein à
l'amorce d'une semaine de Ford
mobilisation j'ai un peu posé la même
question dans le premier débat mais
c'est pas un cadeau fait par élève au
gouvernement le fond de ma pensée c'est
que tous les acteurs elle a l'air
comprit sont parfaitement conscients des
limites potentiellement
constitutionnelles d'un tel sujet et
qu'en réalité on est sur de la posture
politique ce qui est de bonne guerre si
vous me permettez l'expression de la
part de LR dans la période pour envoyer
un signal sur le thème nous sommes les
gardiens de la tranquillité des usagers
etc et de la garantie des usagers de
pouvoir utiliser les moyens de transport
bon voilà je pense que ça s'arrête là
parce qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure il y a beaucoup de scie
il y a c'est une matière qui faut
regarder avec beaucoup de précautions ça
s'est vu notamment à travers les textes
antérieurs qui ont pu exister en la
matière sur le service minimum et sur
toute la difficulté de trouver le point
d'équilibre sous l'oeil vigilant et du
Conseil d'État et du Conseil
constitutionnel entre le fait d'assurer
la liberté d'aller venir et le
fonctionnement des services essentiels
et puis le respect du droit de grève et
donc cette limite elle est toujours
extrêmement complexe à ciseler à trouver
avec un certain nombre de garanties on
peut aller sans doute plus loin sur
certains sujets par exemple sur le champ
du service minimum dans un certain
nombre de cas mais là pour le coup enfin
d'après ce qu'on peut entendre on va
assez loin et sans doute au-delà d'un
certain nombre de limites qui seraient
admises Mathieu ce qui frappant c'est
que c'est provocations j'allais dire
identitaire de la droite on est bien à
droite on n'a pas bougé ben en fait elle
servent une chose plutôt le gouvernement
à se recentrer et pouvoir être affiché
une espèce de profil de modération en
disant on n'est pas dans la rue avec les
opposants mais on n'est pas non plus la
droite donc c'est pas un peu
contre-productif dans l'équation de ce
de ce mouvement qui peut faire plier ou
pas on verra le le gouvernement il y a
souvent la jeunesse les lycéens les
étudiants du haut de ses 22 ans le
député la France insoumise Louis Boyard
le sait bien et c'est donc chargé de
lancer cet appel sur les réseaux les
médias sociaux cette mars toute la
France sera bloquée contre la réforme
des retraites et parce que cette réforme
nous concerne nous aussi les jeunes on
s'attend à ce que tous les lycées et
toutes les universités soient bloquées
contre la réforme des retraites et
pourquoi on lance le hashtag blocus
challenge postez vos plus belles photos
de blocus de lycée et d'université parmi
ces photos on en tirera une sorte et
l'équipe de bloqueurs sera invité à
visiter l'Assemblée nationale avec nous
donc on se retrouve le mardi 7 mars pour
mettre le pays à l'arrêt et participer
au blocus challenge on se retrouve mardi
pour faire reculer ma pour faire reculer
Macron appelle le café bondir la
Présidente de la Région Île-de-France
Valérie Pécresse réaction sur Twitter
elle porte plainte elle dit le droit de
manifester doit respecter le droit
d'étudier j'ai essayé de porter plainte
au nom de la région pour incitation des
d'entraves incitations à la violence
leur Salvin les insoumis bon on le sait
ils sont pas représentés au Sénat leur
stratégie d'obstruction à l'assemblé
national est plutôt été critiquée par
l'opinion mais surtout par les leaders
syndicaux qui voulaient absolument aller
jusqu'à l'examen de l'article 7 sur le
report de de l'âge légal cet appel c'est
le moyen d'exister médiatiquement la
preuve c'est réussi on en parle
absolument mais je pense qu'ils ont
besoin effectivement de de peser aussi
dans les pas ils voient bien que les
choses sont en train un peu de leur
échapper quand on regarde l'image des
parties politiques
c'est pareil c'est pas c'est un peu
comme les leaders syndicaux c'est pas
terrible on a plutôt justement une
dégradation de l'image des partis
politiques et y compris des parties de
gauche il y en a un seul qui tire son
épingle du jeu parti politique c'est le
RN qui voit son image progressive
c'est-à-dire que la discrétion choisie
par le RN elle paye exactement la
discrétion le choix aussi de finalement
de jouer le jeu de l'Assemblée nationale
et pas forcément de d'appeler aux
manifestations etc la tranquillité
apparente en tout cas
davantage aujourd'hui le rassemblement
national en terme d'image il atteint le
plus haut de son de ce score de son
score 33% des Français aujourd'hui ont
une bonne image du rassemblement
national pas du tout ces chiffres par
ailleurs et puis une dernière chose sur
les jeunes ce qu'on voit dans les
derniers jours là donc c'est avoir si ça
se confirme mais
paradoxalement chez les jeunes on voit
une une approbation à l'égard de cette
mobilisation qui fléchit un peu au
profit de l'indifférence les plus jeunes
aujourd'hui se disent cette réforme des
retraites ça commence un peu quand même
à nous agacer c'est pas non plus
complètement notre sujet et il y a un
petit peu plus d'indifférence ces
derniers jours qu'il y a encore quelques
semaines chez les plus jeunes il faut
peut-être là aussi refaire un peu
d'histoire
pourquoi c'est ce qui est le plus
surveillé peut-être par les
gouvernements la mobilisation des
lycéens ou des étudiants parce que il y
a des exemples de réformes qui ont été
remises dans les tiroirs après la
mobilisation de la jeunesse
des facteurs qui pourraient perturber le
la séquence tout écrite des
manifestations sans lendemain c'est
effectivement la jeunesse et on l'a vu
en 2006 à l'occasion de démobilisation
sur le CPE comme quand la jeunesse est
dans la rue c'est extrêmement difficile
et le président Chirac avait dû ne pas
promulguer autant que je me souvienne
parce qu'elle avait malgré tout elle
avait été voté un restaurant le CPE donc
un contrat premier embauche donc là les
jeunes étaient directement visés ils ont
bougé énormément parce que c'est une
mesure qui les ciblée là c'est vrai que
la question des retraites bon les jeunes
à 16 17 18 ans il y en a pas beaucoup
qui se projettent jusqu'à la retraite
mais c'est comme ça discute dans les
familles malgré tout c'est un sujet qui
peut qui peut les faire bouger je crois
que c'est ce qui explique quel que soit
la forme la la cette idée d'aller de
stimuler les jeunes pour que il descende
dans la rue le 7 et après mais bon c'est
pas gagné mais je pense que il y a cette
idée de jouer là-dessus parce que bon la
grève dans le privé elle va être dure
enracinée la violence on n'est pas très
pour par contre les jeunes ça serait un
facteur qui déstabiliserait le
gouvernement un mot de conclusion du
reste moins d'une minute pourquoi de
l'intérieur de votre expérience
ministérielle pourquoi ça fait si peur
un gouvernement parce que les dernières
situations où le gouvernement a dû
retirer des réformes vous l'avez rappelé
c'était en 2006 et il y a une autre
précédent avant chaque fois c'était dans
le contexte de mouvement de jeunesse
important
c'est pour ça je pense qu'effectivement
les pouvoirs publics vont être très
vigilants sur ce sur ce sujet et font en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de prise dans la
réforme via des sujets qui
concerneraient des universités ou qui
concerneraient des questions qui
concerneraient plus particulièrement les
jeunes pour que se développe ce type de
mouvement merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat à cette
émission j'aimerais Pernot je rappelle
le titre de votre livre le syndicalisme
d'après qui est publié aux éditions du
détour pas de sens public demain
priorité au débat en séance et donc
notamment si le calendrier respecté
à l'article 7 qui devrait être examiné à
partir du début de soirée ici au Sénat
votre prochain rendez-vous sinon dans
nos émissions dans la matinée alors
également signé reçoit François Aubry
dans quel président de la CFE CGC
principal syndicat de cadre je vous dis
à très vite belle soirée